لو تعطينا فكره عن حجم نشاطاتكم
والتمويلات التي منحتوها حتى الان
بالنسبه لصندوقنا بخمسه وثلاثين فرصه
استثماريه اعلنا عن 32 وان شاء الله سنعمل
عن ثلاثه قادمين
كصندوق لا نعلم بالضبط كم نستثمر لكن في
مراحل
او ما قبل البذره والبذره الشكل الاولي من
100 الف الى 300 الف دولار امريكي وشرك
السيد من 300 الى الى مليون ما يعادل
تقريبا فيك تعطينا فكره عن على ماذا تركزت
هذه الفرص التي منحتوها تمويل حتى الان
بالنسبه لصندوقنا احنا ما نسمى
بمعنى انه ما في اي مجال معين نريد ان نرى
كلمه تك في الشركه التقنيه الناشئه
لكن في مجالات اهم من مجالات يعني بنتك في
في في وطننا العربي يحظى باهتمام كثير من
ناحيه التقييم من ناحيه فرص التخرج فبكون
عليها تركيز اكثر من امور قد تكون مثلا في
المحتوى او الكيمنج كلها مهمه لكن في يعني
بعض المجالات اهم من مجالات اخرى طيب في
اي مرحله يبدو نظام الشركات الناشئه في
المنطقه العربيه حاليا هل يمكننا ان نقول
انه بلاغ مرحله النضوج
بالنسبه لقانون الشركات احنا في بدايه
الطريق او يعني في الحجر الاساس اليوم
كسناديق مثل صندوق نمى اللي يستثمر في
مستخدم
او يعني القروض القابله للتحول الى الى
اسد الى الى اسهم
واشهرها حاضنه واي كومبليتر عندها
للاسف اليوم لا نستطيع ان نستخدم بعض هذه
الادوات في قوانين الشركات
المحليه ولذلك نطلب من
شركاتنا شركات تقنيه في منطقتنا ان تؤسس
الهولدينج القابضه في اماكن
القانون الشركات فيها ناضج بحيث تستحوذ
هذه الشركات القابضه على الشركات المحليه
100% في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وزاره
الاستثمار تقدم هذا الخدمه من خلال
انترنوش لانه نحن كصندوق راس مال جريء
نستثمر باقليه ولكن محوكب نطلب بعض الحقوق
حقوق معرفه حقوق محافظه على النسب لا يمكن
تطبيقها اليوم في قوانين الشركات الحاليه
ولكن ابشرك قانون الشركات السعودي الجديد
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه الجديد يعالج
99% من هذه المشكله ونحن يعني متحمسين جدا
في يعني صدد يعني